Many people come to me and they see how
courageous they see me.
And very often,
uh,
maybe in shocking way I said,
but I don't find myself courageous.
I,
I find myself passionate and I love what
I do.
And if I love what I do,
I'm going to do it all day long.
And if I do it all day long,
I probably will be very good at it soon.
And that's the story of my life.
I started,
I was not born,
uh,
in the [inaudible] for example,
where the wire walkers are.
So I learned by myself.
Yeah.
As I was learning all my arts,
magic,
juggling the high wire,
writing books,
making films,
all those things.
I realize maybe by looking at performers
and also by,
uh,
becoming one that the most powerful way
to inspire people to touch in audience
is not to try to touch them,
is to be yourself.
If you write a novel for what the people
want to weed while you do a wider than
that will be an interested in.
But if you're right,
because you are divorced inside by a
fire and then you need to write,
or the painter needs to paint,
um,
then,
then your work,
um,
will be interesting.
And actually some people may hate it.
Oh My,
love it.
Which actually are distant cousins.
It's much more interesting than people
says,
oh,
I don't remember that work of art.
Um,
but you will cause a,
a human response much more,
which that if you try to please,
if you try to,
you know,
in,
in performance,
in show business,
and I hate that term.
You see people on stage,
a juggler,
imagination.
They tried to make the people love the,
try to make them upload.
And by doing that,
they take away from their art.
Uh,
you have to find your own personality,
your own style,
and that takes sometimes a lifetime or
you can copy people and that's,
you know,
an artistic crime.
Um,
but to go the easy way in to try to be a
crowd pleaser at a very young age in my
life,
I realize that was a form of,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible].